leg you deviated then the energy is
coming in so you move out of the
way he
goes move
[Music]
he goes hey
maker
disappear and come on let's
go see where I I'm tucked on this back
corner you see that like kind of like a
boxer I'm just tuck right here so he
can't elbow me or hit me
go my chest is on his chest okay don't
come here and then you have this space
here hug
[Music]
him
faster okay try it so now we go pull em
take this
leg oh this leg
just picking up you you have enough
right use momentum right there but when
you lift the
leg okay so not all of you can take your
KY so you're just going to go
slow
one up just sort of
push then draw your
weon in that corner ride the energy
lift draw the weapon back to a grip Dr
okay let's go
in all right pull down right here
cuz you don't want you don't want to be
here you see so you have to immediately
get the centrifugal energy going and the
angle
cancellation so here
go go
slow okay let's go
see I'm right here
not out
here
[Music]
okay see how I I already have you okay
then your energy is taking me so I move
out the way of the
energy don't think you're going to is a
punch and you're going to stay there
he's bigger than you you're going to go
that way you understand so you deviate
it then the energy is coming in so you
move out of the
way okay let's go
hereos
[Applause]
again you see how I never lost lost
contact with them
right okay let's try it
oh
okay watch High stick
okay let's